[Musica]
sono passati poco più di dieci anni da
quando i social network sono arrivati
nella nostra società e sono diventati
parte della nostra quotidianità
dieci anni in cui è cambiato
praticamente tutto
quando parliamo di internet oggi ci
chiediamo spesso se la rete ci stia
rendendo più di attori più isolati più
disinformati più polarizzati ogni giorno
le notizie che leggiamo ci raccontano di
un mondo in cui sui social si litiga le
persone non sono più capaci di parlarsi
senza insultarsi e così noi non capiamo
bene che cosa sta succedendo ma è
davvero così
ci chiediamo spesso appunto se internet
città rendendo più di autori però forse
dovremmo cominciare a cambiare i focus
delle domande per capire davvero che
cosa sta succedendo con le piattaforme e
se davvero le piattaforme che erano
state create per unirci oggi siano
responsabili di una profonda
frammentazione sociale come facciamo a
capirne i motivi
vi voglio lanciare una provocazione se
invece di chiederci se i social ci
stanno rendendo solo più odiatori o più
disinformati cominciassimo a chiederci
se ci stanno rendendo più diseguali
cambiando questa prospettiva e parlando
di disuguaglianza forse appunto
troveremo delle risposte nuove
parlare di disuguaglianza quando
parliamo di internet
vuol dire prima di tutto parlare non
solo di odio online e non solo di
disinformazione ma parlare di una cosa
di cui sentiamo molto poco parlare
ovvero i dati i dati che sono il nucleo
della società digitale
ecco i dati e sono responsabili in
qualche modo del funzionamento della
nostra società e quando parliamo di dati
disuguaglianza questo ci serve per
chiederci chi possiede questi dati e
soprattutto con quali obiettivi
una delle prime cose a cui dobbiamo
pensare quando parliamo di dati e quindi
è appunto chi li possiede e cercate di
sfatare dei miti anche sui dati a noi
viene spontaneo pensare che i dati siano
rappresentativi delle persone e fin da
quando siamo piccoli ci insegnano che la
matematica non è un'opinione quindi
automaticamente ci viene da pensare che
ciò che poi fa funzionare questi dati li
aggrega ovvero gli algoritmi che sono
quello che dà il funzionamento a tutte
le applicazioni che usiamo a tutte le
piattaforme che usiamo siano qualcosa di
neutrale ma non è così non è così la
tecnologia non è neutrale e questa è una
cosa che dobbiamo tenere davvero a mente
perché la tecnologia è un prodotto umano
dietro ad ogni algoritmo dietro ogni
applicazione e dietro ogni piattaforma
c'è un essere umano con una propria
visione del mondo con delle proprie idee
con dei propri obiettivi
ed è proprio questo il primo passo per
cominciare a adottare un pensiero
critico verso tutte le piattaforme che
utilizziamo alzi la mano chi non ha mai
sentito la frase se il servizio è gratis
il prodotto sei tu è infatti piuttosto
risaputo che le piattaforme della
silicon valley sono dei grossi monopoli
privati che possiedono i nostri dati e
possiedono gli strumenti per analizzarli
e fanno questo
a fine di lucro per creare delle
pubblicità sempre più personalizzate
ormai le piattaforme sono parte
dell'infrastruttura sociale noi li
usiamo per qualsiasi cosa da prenotare
una macchina un ristorante a tenere
sotto controllo la nostra salute trovare
un partner
però facciamo ancora fatica a capire
come questi algoritmi funzionano e
soprattutto poi questi dati dove vadano
con chi vengano condivisi
quando parlo di queste cose
e lo faccio spesso infatti ormai miei
amici mi odiano e una delle cose che mi
viene chiesta è ma perché me ne dovrei
occupare cioè alla fine a me le
pubblicità personalizzate non danno
fastidio
cioè io so cosa comprare o comunque
della mia privacy
mi importa relativamente perché non ho
niente da nascondere
quando parliamo di privacy prima di
tutto dobbiamo pensare alla privacy come
un diritto umano e quindi la privacy non
ha mai avuto a che vedere con l'idea di
non aver niente da nascondere ma
piuttosto con la nostra libertà di
ricavarci uno spazio autonomo e libero
da interferenze esterne tanto private
quanto pubbliche ma soprattutto io credo
che quando parliamo di privacy oggi nel
2019 dobbiamo pensare alla privacy come
un diritto collettivo non solo
individuale
vi faccio un esempio
siccome gli algoritmi quello che fanno
non è aggregare tanto i dati gli
individui o piuttosto i dati i gruppi
quello che succede è che poi gli
algoritmi molto spesso sono in grado
anche di conoscere le nostre debolezze e
utilizzarle a scopo di lucro per
l'appunto gli algoritmi oggi vengono
utilizzati già per prendere delle
decisioni anche sociali ad esempio negli
stati uniti o in australia già si
utilizzano gli algoritmi per decidere se
una persona merita un lavoro o se una
persona è più o meno potenziale
criminale se merita un mutuo ecco questi
sono degli esempi che ci insegnano che
come abbiamo detto gli algoritmi non
sono neutrali perché se l'algoritmo non
è neutrale
quello che farà è utilizzare o comunque
vedere i pregiudizi che ci sono dentro
alla società e riprodurli ed espanderli
quindi sono diventati molto famosi casi
in cui per esempio come quello che
vedete alle mie spalle un algoritmo
negli stati unini decideva se una
persona fosse più o meno potenziale
criminale risultava discriminante verso
i neri oppure l'algoritmo di amazon che
a un certo punto tramite intelligenza
artificiale decideva se
persona fosse più o meno valido per fare
parte dell'azienda e risultava
discriminante verso le donne perché
perché se la nostra società ci dice che
i neri sono più probabili criminale dei
bianchi l'algoritmo dirà la stessa cosa
e se la società ci dice che le donne
sono meno valide degli uomini per fare i
lavori di leadership
l'algoritmo dire la stessa cosa ecco
perché è un problema collettivo perché
l'algoritmo riproduce la cultura
dominante ma vi voglio fare un altro
esempio ci sono casi come cambridge
analitica o il caso snowden che ci hanno
insegnato che più spesso di quello che
pensiamo
le piattaforme utilizzano i nostri dati
e le condividono non solo con altre
aziende ma anche con gli stati con i
governi che li utilizzano per conoscere
i nostri movimenti le nostre
conversazioni per spiarci questo
ovviamente è molto problematico e vi
faccio un esempio io sono un attivista
per gli attivisti che sono coloro che
per definizione mettono in discussione
il potere e cercano cambiamento sociale
la sorveglianza significa controllo
questo è già successo in francia non
tanto distante da noi quando nel 2015
in seguito alla dichiarazione dello
stato di emergenza dopo gli attentati
terroristici
il governo francese comincia a seguire
espiare gli attivisti ecologisti per
evitare che manifestassero in questo
senso il diritto alla privacy è quello
che si lega ad altri ad altri diritti
come la il diritto a manifestare il
diritto di organizzazione la libertà di
espressione sono tutti i diritti che
hanno a che vedere con noi non stiamo
parlando solo dei miei dati stiamo
parlando dei nostri dati quindi quando
parliamo di società digitale
io credo che sia molto importante che
ricominciamo a vederci come parte di una
comunità e cominciamo a pensare ai
nostri dati come un bene comune
oltre questo dobbiamo cominciare adatta
ad adottare uno sguardo critico in cui
cominciamo a chiedere noi di decidere
che cosa e privato che cos'è pubblico
cominciamo a mettere in discussione
questo
il ruolo di cittadini consumatori in cui
non celato scegliere e sono dei privati
a scegliere i termini e le condizioni
della nostra partecipazione sociale e
della nostra visibilità online dei
contenuti che consumiamo che
contribuiscono a creare la nostra
visione del mondo
dobbiamo veramente riaprire un dibattito
completamente nuovo e dobbiamo
cominciare a fissare dei limiti etici
in questo senso dobbiamo imparare dal
passato perché se pensiamo per esempio
al petrolio il petrolio è stata una
risorsa che ci ha permesso di
svilupparci come società in una maniera
incredibile però forse sarebbe stato
meglio renderci conto prima che dovevamo
regolamentare le aziende prima di
svegliarsi nel mezzo del cambiamento
climatico
ecco non possiamo lasciare che con
internet sta cosa dobbiamo fissare dei
limiti
dopo avervi terrorizzati vorrei però
provare a lasciarvi anche un po di
speranza raccontandovi anche la mia
esperienza come attivista io appunto di
questi temi mi sono sempre interessata
ho cominciato studiandoli e poi a un
certo punto ho cercato di capire come li
potevo portare fuori dall'università e
ho capito la prima cosa che ho capito è
stata che per capire come risolvere i
problemi su internet dobbiamo sempre
parlare dell'intersezione tra società
tecnologia politica economia non
possiamo fidarci di coloro che ci
offrono soluzioni sono tecniche o solo
giuridiche circa un anno fa
sono diventata il volto di questa
campagna che si chiama intimità violata
ancora oggi sono emozionata dirlo perché
nel giro di pochissimi mesi da una
petizione su change.org siamo passati ad
avere una legge e come è stato fatto
questo è stata creata prima di tutto una
rete ampissima di esperti che è una cosa
che oggi facciamo sempre meno no
consultare gli esperti
beh per l'intimità violata e per il
revenge iporn la condivisione non
consensuale di materiale intimo
abbiamo avuto bisogno di consultare non
solo giuristi non solo politici ma anche
informatici psicologi sociologi
insomma abbiamo veramente creato una
rete dal basso per fare in modo di
approcciarci a questi problemi nel modo
giusto e questo è stato molto importante
perché nel nostro percorso
c'è stato chi proponeva delle soluzioni
alternative alle nostre come per esempio
appunto solo la legge ad esempio c'era
chi proponeva di vietare il sexting
ovvero lo scambio di video foto intime
tra partner all'anno di fatto a
censurare la libertà di espressione dei
cittadini
oppure c'è chi proponeva solo soluzioni
tecniche dicendo beh implementiamo il
fingerprinting dell'impronta digitale
creiamo dei grossi archivi online in cui
tutte le foto che sono sulle piattaforme
sono schedate insieme e in questo modo
rimuoveremo il materiale più rapidamente
andando a creare di fatto problemi per
la sorveglianza dei cittadini ecco
questo è un esempio per dire che quando
parliamo di internet di problemi
dobbiamo veramente adottare uno sguardo
sociale e culturale cioè renderci conto
che come il revenge porno per esempio
non nasce da internet ma nasce da una
violenza che è già presente nella
società
quella contro le donne allo stesso modo
l'odio online non lo risolveremo solo
parlando di far iscrivere i cittadini
sulle piattaforme con un documento o il
problema dei monopoli su internet non lo
risolveremo utilizzando tecnologie nuove
come la block chain perché non esiste la
causa e l'effetto dell'utilizzo di una
tecnologia dobbiamo pensare in una
maniera completamente nuova per fare
questo ci sono due cose che possiamo
fare
la prima è educarci dobbiamo conoscere i
nostri diritti per potersi difendere
dobbiamo parlare del problema
dell'accentramento di poteri su internet
con i monopoli
dobbiamo parlare di come funzionano le
piattaforme dobbiamo cominciare a
chiedere noi che cosa vogliamo e
dobbiamo parlare di cose private di
cos'è pubblico
l'altra cosa è un irsifar attivismo a me
piace molto in questo caso citare e
greta tube che dice activism works
l'attivismo funziona ed è davvero così
forse noi ancora dentro al nostro
sguardo un po individualista che ci
siamo abituati ad adottare ci siamo
dimenticati della potenza di tante
persone che si mettono insieme per
portare avanti qualcosa però la verità è
che se vogliamo cambiamento sociale
dobbiamo ricominciare a guardarci perché
qui
quando parliamo di diritti digitali
parliamo del futuro della nostra
democrazia
parliamo del fatto che dobbiamo
chiederci come fare a risolvere
l'immensa forbice sociale che le
piattaforme stanno creando e come
risolvere veramente l'odio online questo
appunto sarà un processo molto lungo
però credo che sarà l'unica cosa che che
possiamo davvero fare anche perché
dobbiamo veramente parlare di quello che
internet può fare non solo dei problemi
che causa nel senso che internet non
solo del mio caso ma nel mondo è stato
responsabile della espansione dei
movimenti sociali da meet you è
diventato uno strumento per fare in modo
che le persone si potessero unire sulla
rete e allo stesso tempo può creare
anche degli spazi sicuri per le persone
per parlarsi per le comunità
discriminate quindi crediamoci nel fatto
che internet ci possa aiutare però prima
chiediamoci dove stiamo andando siamo in
un momento cruciale della storia e
dobbiamo veramente veramente cominciare
a lavorare insieme
una delle cose che ho imparato
quest'anno è che le persone ti diranno
sempre che non cambia mai niente che non
possiamo fare niente che le cose sono
così però quello che io oggi spero di
potervi lasciare è che non è vero non è
vero perché io ho cominciato da zero e
oggi sono qui ed è stato solo perché ci
ho creduto quindi crediamoci nei nostri
diritti
iamm crediamo nelle nostre libertà
e crediamo nel cambiamento grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]